la victime est un homme un palestinien
mahmoud el mahfoudi qu'il s'agit de 50
ans les experts s'accordent au point
attribué cette opération au mostra et
plus précisément au qui doit on peut
m'expliquer qui donne à notre unité
assassinat ils ont rien à voir avec nous
on sait pas qui sont ces clowns on les
connaît pas daniel levy 38 ans né en
france un as de l'arnaqué c'est fait on
en change antoine simon surnommé
facebook comme facebook et la vie sauve
à 25 ans l'étudiante qui m'a appelé
erik lyman dîner bien ils croient tous
les trois qu'il bosse pour le mossad
c'est un sport non année les temps
devant l'hôtel quelques dizaines de
secondes vappereau et alors vous avez
fait quoi alors improvisé
j'ai été bien discret mais c'est un truc
qui fonctionne pas ses toiles en sportif
avec des jambes de crevettes ça
fonctionne pas du tout
l'ordinateur de mahmur peut-être il
contient des informations cruciales sur
le programme nucléaire iranien ou gelée
dire non vous avez les ordinateurs eu
bien sûr eux connaîtront un diamant non
mais tu as besoin sur les jambes
nous on regarde reste rassurant c'est
que ce soit quand on regarde c'est parti
vous allez faire le ménage c'est pas
aussi simple ce que tu peux
minot
s'il te plaît [ __ ] c'est trop cool mon
gadget c'est un faux alors t'emballe pas